hello
are we live
well hello there
welcome
how are we doing today
welcome welcome hi sinks how are you
scully grant alexa
rapid ash
ahmed kevin newt
what up people
what's up yesterday looking forward to
the stream well thank you i appreciate
you being here
thank you very much
i binge watched the rest of your lore
videos and want to ask them go for it
man
that's why we're here
i'm goodsyncs how are you man
freeze ant
freeze ant
yeah no bots allowed i agree metal no
bots
allowed we don't like bots here and me
just saying the word bots is probably
gonna trigger some youtube bots
and that'll be weird
but we'll ban them
hopefully the weather is tolerable
tolerable
the last two weeks here it's been
absolutely insane it's been like
crazy hot and humid but it's actually
finally starting to let up a little bit
so
that's nice wait hold on i gotta do
something real quick
let's see if this works
but hopefully everyone is having a great
day
hoggers in the chat
are we allowed to say pogba's here
are we allowed to say pogba's
i think so
wait is this how it's supposed to be
okay now the chat fades at the top and i
really like that
huge huge
monka
how come you haven't included any of
melania's quoting
queen america's words and any lore
videos
uh
i have many times
many a time
so maybe you haven't gone far enough
back i guess i'm not sure
i lived in north carolina it's supposed
to be dry but it has been humid yeah i'm
not a huge i don't mind heat i really
don't
heat's fine to me
it's when
it's humid
that i really don't like
not a fan of humidity where i just walk
outside and i just instantly start
sweating
not a fan
other than that though
we're good
we're good
cool video idea would be to talk about
the sun eclipse
that is related to the walking
mausoleums i actually just watched a
video about that by somebody else
i think if you look up elden ring
eclipse you'll probably find it
it was just randomly in my recommended
and i'm like
i have seen an eclipse in this game
before
have you guys noticed that like if you
if you wait long enough i'm i think it's
in in limb grave every now and then
there will be an eclipse
you'll be like what
and then it'll go away it lasts like two
seconds
i love your videos no i'm not spammed
just reposting because i wasn't sure
you'd see it i appreciate that
thank you raven thank you
i'm glad you like them
yeah solar eclipse like the moon
covering whatever part of the sun there
is
can you explain it again because i like
your voice i i hate my voice
i hate it you guys notice that i have a
very very slight lisp
it's it's really not noticeable very
often but sometimes my s's just don't
hit they just don't let's go
then i have to you know re-record it
because i hear it like i i don't like my
voice personally i don't think anybody
likes their voice so it's whatever
i think something on the map appears
during an eclipse
i don't know how you would be able to
react to it if you knew where to go
potentially
i'm not sure
new secrets i've actually only made one
video
uh like weird but interesting uh
finds discoveries i've only made one of
those and actually did really well
it's kind of hard to find those things
to be honest
yeah chips we talked about that uh last
stream
for a little bit
the the mausoleums are
i mean each one has a
soulless demigod in it yeah
yeah if you guys if you guys have
theories run it by me that's why we're
here
that's why we're here baby
to talk about stuff
you should play dark souls 3 on stream
that is a part of the plan
i have 1500 hours in dark souls 3. i'm
pretty sure we could beat that game in
one day like very easily actually i i
know i could beat it in one day
do you ever listen to your voice
in a video and cringe all the time every
video i make i cringe
just at my voice
i actually really like my videos
which i think every creator should do
like
if you're a content creator and you
don't like your own videos then you got
a bit of a problem
but i like mine
it adds character shows that you're
human don't be ashamed or embarrassed
i'm not i just don't like it that's
that's all i'm not embarrassed or
ashamed of it if i was i wouldn't make
videos
but uh
yeah i'm good it's fine
am i allowed to curse and chat
absolutely [ __ ] not
how [ __ ] dare you curse in my [ __ ]
chat
yeah you can it's fine
i like my voice it's fine i just don't
like my lisp
that's all
yeah [ __ ] around find out people
i don't think radon is mindless i think
he's still aware of what's going on
uh he's self-isolating and the most part
of caleb protects his horse
might even be behind the radon festival
i mean
yeah
i think he is still in there somewhere
he just can't like control himself
you know
you just can't
you know yeah he does protect his horse
he is like still in the caled wilds
just eating corpses instead of like
regular people
i think radon is like the coolest
character in this game in my opinion
cursed ever to wander
yeah i mean that's the theory is that
he's wandering whoa
upside down there we go
oh we're still upside down
what ebbs what up moe
nerd
i love this area
this looks so cool in here
the 180.
i think reichard's serpent only grew as
big as it did because reichard had some
type of giantism in him
also could be a reason why the serpent
is around the heat of the volcano manor
to please the fire god
that's very possible
my knowledge the
serpent is a
the serpent is an outer god right
uh oh joy's very upset at something out
the window
uh oh
she is barking
aggressively
i want to know who the moog before the
frenzy flame
is i'm assuming just a projection or a
summon of him of himself
kind of like uh morgot does with
margaret
are we still still looking into mykla i
mean yeah we haven't really we're just
talking right now we haven't gone on a
i'm sure something will come up where we
just we go on that
we're just talking right now we just
started
welcome
a blasphemy
i mean we we see in the intro that the
the serpent is
small in the intro when he's eating
reichardt
and then obviously grows a lot bigger
but i i just equated that to
they ate a lot of people
like if you look in the
let's see
if you look in this boss room
uh the entire
the entire thing is just filled with
corpses i'm gonna walk right into lava
right here
excellent
let's leave him alone
there's just bodies why are you
attacking me oh god
you're not supposed to attack me
you forehead
hold on
that i just equated that to them uh
eating a lot of people you know what i'm
saying
there we go
that's what we want
he's a hungry boy he tried to eat me
i fell through the ground
excellent
he saw rick and he went after him he
tried to eat the god that is rick okay
there we go
yeah it's all corpses everywhere on the
ground
everywhere
which also brings up the question at
what are they eating
why are all these here
i guess it's all skull and bones so
they're eating all the flesh of them
they don't want it
the uh the god devouring serpent doesn't
like bones
join the serpent king as family
here let's actually get him to
[Music]
stage two
i here i've ever attacked you with
anything other than the serpent killer
could do this
this is pretty strong
you know if they reach you
oh
[Music]
ego boom
i don't know why i have two wondrous
physics
oh yeah we're gonna watch the cutscene
the elden beast has no bones therefore
is a snake snack
great theory
rickard wanted the power to devour the
gods but he
could be the same motives as being the
giants fire giants worship
being wanted to devour the gods as he
could but why america wanted to be rid
of the giants
did america want to be rid of the giants
or was that the greater will
i don't think america decided anything
oh they poop them out interesting
i don't know much about snakes either i
don't like snakes
i've made one video on reichard
and honestly it's because i don't like
snakes
what is the breaking point between
america and the greater will
the breaking point
i would think would just be
maybe killing godwin
but i think she had a part in that
all right card
ew
this boy nasty
he looks like zoned out in high
doesn't he
and what way did reichardt assist ronnie
from my understanding he took
he took all the blame
he took all the blame
for my understanding of
everything
that she technically did
do you think more people are fused
together like america and ronnie
yes
i do
i just don't know exactly who yet
don't know exactly who
this is a crown
yeah kinda
i love this free cam so we can just go
up and look at stuff
what do these look like
something in this cage
no
hmm
anything in here what's this
candles really
damn this place goes back far holy [ __ ]
okay
what is this
wait what's this like
thing wrapped around right here
you see that like right in the middle of
the
why is it wrapped around like that the
heck
weird
could ronnie be fused with melania in a
way i don't
think so
it's
shedding is it
i think you're right
yeah look it is shedding right here look
at
that i've never noticed that before
he is actually shedding his skin that's
a good point
yeah all of this looks like dead skin
back here
oh hello
hi
gross dude this thing is so disgusting
do
what kind of rings we rock in here
a lot of them
they answer that question
a lot of them
so this boy's just dead
does his eye move at all
no i think he's dead
we need to find more out about malakath
i would love that too we to find
everything out about this game
but that seems impossible
i mean the blast the big blasphemous act
would be going against the greater will
feeding himself to the serpent
um
to seek more power and then
i guess it doesn't say anywhere that he
said
that he was
a part of the knight of black knives
does it
does it say that anywhere
oh yeah he also fed himself to the
serpent
while he had his great rune
we need a podcast with every creator
smoketown actually does that he's only
done it once though
i wish he'd do it again
because that that was a cool uh podcast
he did a couple months ago
yeah i would say just feeding himself to
the serpent was the blasphemous part
yeah i don't think reichardt's really
that bad of a guy
just doesn't like the greater will
little he he's staring at his uh dagger
here
staring it down
which i believe we have this weapon
does anyone know what this uh weapon's
called
right here
how do you say this quinn
quincueda
i just said that so wrong didn't i short
sword given to a high ranking clergyman
of pharah missoula
really raises potency of bcl
indentations the design celebrates a
beast five fingers
symbolic of the intelligence once
granted upon their kind
this design celebrates a beast's five
fingers symbolic of the intelligence
once granted upon their kind that is
interesting
cincadia
finn k dia thank you
hi teflon how are you
uh didn't mean to be rude stayed up
brainstorming
oh i just didn't see it nuked i'm sorry
didn't see it
is it is this saying that there's a five
fingers
like a b steel five fingers
is there a gloam eye on the end of it
wait a minute
do you see that
can i look at it here
or he's gonna be holding it no he's not
what is that
it's kind of purpley silvery
it's a rock
it's a rock
it looks like the beast eye
isn't that a key item
yup
claw marked stone eye received him grant
is said to tremble near death root the
murky violet iris reaps as if alive i am
not sated feed me more death
it's not just a boulder
it's a rock
could it be kind of like gravity magic
because you are like kind of moving
earth
you know
maybe that uses gravity
that's a stretch
that's a stretch big
boy i think god of freud is godwin's son
and godric's dad
who was erased from history for creating
grafting explains why he only mentioned
his only mention is in the ancient
dragon night summon
yeah is like
wait that's god of roy's only mention
ancient dragon night summon
let's see
ancient dragon knight
seems important
like a big one
kristoff
has to be
used to summon spirit of kristoff spirit
of kristoff an honorable knight of
landel who is also devout worshiper of
the ancient dragons
the skills strike down foes with
thunderbolts the dragon's weapon of
choice after the first defense of
aryandel kristoff earned the hero's
honor
of urgery burial for the feat of
capturing
god of roy the grafton
i have not heard that before that's a
that's that's big nice
so why
is
is god free
like wanted
hmm
we're kind of all over place right now
we got we got to focus on some
that's how these will always start
though
is this like talking about random stuff
look at the elden ring behind malakath
yeah it's different
who do you guys think this is right here
before i look at that who do you think
this is
is this like an empirian with her
shadows
is this queen america
i don't really know what her hair looks
like
kind of a kid america
with her shadows
is this does this tell us that she has
more than one
three-headed dog
no i think they yeah they all have
separate bodies
i don't think this could be saint trina
kind of reminds me of selen's crown
let's take a look at that it's kind of
like has a
leaf pattern on the side
right
you said this looks like selling
really
yeah that's my question could an
empyrean have more than one shadow
and there's this
oh it's glowing
look at that
see this bottom
why is it glowing right here
oh it's just a part of it
i see
okay sorry
if i had to guess of what this signifies
it signifies roots don't you think or
maybe like fire
does this symbolize the burning of the
elden ring maybe or a shattering of it
kind of i'm just wondering what all
those like waves off of it it's either
like roots fire shattering
something like that
hmm cuz you can definitely see the elden
ring within it for sure
the great tree
i don't know this could symbolize a lot
of
things know what i've never done
just out of curiosity
do we know of more places that we could
do the um
let me get to a side of grace really
quick
what the [ __ ] okay i forgot there was a
tower there
um
you know like in front of that statue
you do the law of aggression regression
and it changes it
oh god i went to the wrong place dog
let's just go here
has anyone ever tested like trying to do
that in different places
i gotta change my memories here
or my spells
imagine we
find something like that let me get rid
of these
we got everything up in her
let's see
ratagan rings of light
what what are all the ones i should try
here in front of it
law of aggression
blog casuality i feel like i should do
some like beast stuff as well right
you guys think it's the crucible
i don't think any like b stuff is really
there
assassin's approach golden vowel
let's try those for now
nicholas rings of light you try that
i'll put on a few
might as well
sorry we're kind of all over the place
right now
i don't know why i want to try the
golden vowel
golden stars triple rings of light
radagon
then you have a proper death
what is this i'm gonna try that
try that
any other ones
some black knife spell
blessing of the herd tree
try that
what is this
that's pretty cool
no i don't think it'd be any like
glintstone stuff
maybe a dragon type of thing
i don't know
has anyone ever tried throwing like a
stone of grank at it like watch it just
break
yeah we're gonna yell at it
all right if i were to stand somewhere
for it to work where do you think it
would be
you think it'd be like in the middle
yeah i do i think it would be like right
here on this stone platform right i
gotta kill him first don't i
[ __ ]
oh god i'm watching it
it'd be front of the wall by the
crucible elden ring as close i don't
think it would be as close as possible
because we don't do that near the stone
wall
eventually have to stand on top of a
message
become my blade once more there's a dude
trying law of progression on every
single thing
good luck to that guy hopefully he finds
something
the original elden ring was the crucible
and the roots were in place replaced by
ratagon
oh yeah his like um
crisscross pattern is that what you're
talking about
i love the music here that's so nice
he might not spawn i'm not gonna cap
nope
what a hype up for nothing huh okay well
is he here
nope
i just realized that he might not spawn
well anyway
yeah we gotta use one of these
okay i was in the wrong spot what i
guess the urgery seal
yeah
all right
attempt number one
law of aggression
oops
nope
law of casuality
that was just nothing dude
i don't know what this is litany of
proper death
it's like a ratagon thing
ratagon's rings of light
lit
you'll hear it shine
blessings of the archery
okay
did not hear it shine
let's throw a stone at it
i short arm that one a bit let's get a
little closer
you think we're out of range i well it
seems to be in like a particular spot
you know but i could get closer
okay that was a good throw
okay not that
lick it
i don't think this is gonna work boys
hmm
what if i flew my camera into it
what's back here
hello
never give up
you think i'm still out of range how do
you know what the range is you don't
so shut your mouth
bucko
hmm
can we see
lim grave from here
yes
or like something
okay
do you think i need to get even closer
are there candles anywhere else
we have candles right here and that's it
oops
how do we blow these out
not a bad idea
imagine
darkness
aspects of the crucible
incantations
okay well i have to go to uh
you should tell me again
is that the tail
yep
we got horn we got oh breath
blow out the candle with fire that would
be weird
uh
we'll try everything
okay
i think malacath will be there again
i should try soap
welcome back all right
breath
i feel like that would light it up
oh
you really want to try gestures
i don't think anything's gonna knock
these
out okay
whoa that was close
raw stomp
we're trying to have something like
potential
of this up here changing or blowing out
these candles here
because are there
literally any other candles on the
ground anywhere near here like on the
ground
that isn't like on that side
get up
no
i feel like if we were gonna do
something it would be right here
just
i don't think it has to do with distance
maybe we do have to defeat him first
okay let me come from the outside
so that i can beat him up like that
because if i try to beat him up in here
his second phase doesn't spawn for some
reason
but we should do that like maybe we have
to beat him first that's a good point
why is what repeating
ruined fragment item description yeah
doesn't that tell you about the um
like the ruins of pharah missoula
falling from the sky and it used to be
over lim grave
what up cud
the ring gesture
let's beat malacath first
i think
i think malacath is the one that put the
spear through america's body
i do
i will not have it stolen from me
again
[Music]
you freeze
oh yeah you do
nice
never seen that before
does anything change over there after we
beat him
we'll we'll come back here after this i
also really like this cutscene
pay attention to the surroundings
could give us a clue
the rune of death
right here looks like the curse mark
that's on uh ronnie's dead corpse
wasn't it
i didn't see anything happen in the
background there
it looks a lot like the curse mark the
rune of death
is unbound
i think the beast eye is like her eye
yeah
and the lands between us shrouded
by death's dark fate
radar wanted the rune of death removed
so all souls recycled in the archery
i think so too yeah
only ronnie cut
only cut half the rune of death into her
two fingers
what do you mean
yet didn't she kill didn't she use the
finger
finger slayer blade
right
how many times did you finish the game
i've beaten this game
dozens of times at this point
who's talking in the cutscene
uh i'm assuming enya
the
finger reader inside the
round table
with the two fingers
because you can go back to this area
right
after you do this
giant mushroom tree go burn
excellent
finger slayer blade looks like a
malformed relic sword
sacred relic sword hold on
um
do you see it
black knife
it's a key item right
wait wait it's a key item
can i keep it
yep
i don't want to zoom
hidden treasure
blood dressed fetish is proof that the
high treason committed by eternal scene
symbolizes downfall
cannot be wielded by those without a
fate what is said to be able to harm the
greater will and its masses
i thought you could hold it
okay let's let's focus here
we think the mycolon boss fight will be
like i don't know if i'm weird for
saying this but i don't think we'll
fight mikala
anybody else
i don't think we'll fight nicola i
really don't
i think we'll talk to him
is he dead
okay
so now we have this here
is there anything different while i'm
sitting here maybe
so i can go out of this like this
just to see
no okay
yeah where do you think i should stand
for this like here just here
let me try this again
no
okay
did those candles go out when i did that
back here
the ones on the right
or is that just textures popping in and
out
see that
10 out of 10 game
hmm
which glintstone crown modeled after
which ronnie is the only known person
with wolves at her command and she stole
the rune of death
here
yeah but why would they like model that
after her here
that would be weird
okay let's try these now
nope
why does this seem like an elevator
right
you see what i'm saying
like i'd step on here
that is a cool ash of war or a
incantation
archery slam
i don't think i tried this one
let's look under
welcome hernia
her ha
whoa
uh
well
there's a potential
that um nothing's loading in here until
my character comes down here right
that is a potential is this whole
platform in elevator look at it it looks
like it should be
right
look at this
this whole play now it's connected to
this bridge right here so never mind
never mind of that
yeah it just goes down into like a abyss
obviously we're not supposed to be down
here
i saw someone using rivers of blood and
it looks terrible now by the way you
guys like the changes that uh like the
new patch
you guys a fan
or nah
i don't know
i guess if you were a rivers of blood
bloodhound step user you'd be mad but
hey
seems good to me
the center could still be an elevator i
i agree it definitely still could be
let's see
what other
i mean should we just try like ground
slam things like imagine i do butt slam
and it triggers the elevator in pharah
missoula that would be sick
so none of those did anything
what could work
lord's heal
did any of these do something
darkness
creates an area of darkness that
conceals the caster
it's out of curiosity
i'm gonna pick some like weird ones
maybe the black blade in that area
because that's where he was
um
is heavy load a
incantation
this one is like stationary maybe that
does something
red lightning
we did see a lot of red lightning here
it has something to do with vike
leading up to this area there was a lot
of that
are doing a jump attack with a spear or
something no i doubt it would be that
simple
maybe though
um
a honed bolt
maybe
corpse
elden stars
i mean maybe that's not a bad call
want me to overload my character
nah
nah
okay let's try those
we can try all the dragon breaths next
okay darkness
what the [ __ ] does that do
that's kind of what
happens after we kill malakath right
is that
i did it closer
hi trey how are you
watch these put out the candles
hmm
no
this is a very interesting
incantation hold on
creates a veil of darkness that conceals
the caster
can be cast in motion or crouching the
assassins were themselves once tarnished
who had strayed from guidance and they
pursued their duty in the darkness that
is without grace
two fingers servants who once served as
the assassins of the round table hold
huh
it's meant to weigh down the elevator i
just don't think that'll work try it
though
assassins of the round table hold who is
that
confessors
this really just looks like an elevator
to me
right here
okay let's try the black blade
maybe i slam it on this thing
might have been a bit too close
oh it's like a it shoots out like that
okay
where does uh it say that that's the
confessors just out of curiosity
hmm
let me try and hit the sign
nothing okay
they're set
let's see
can i use helmet
dedicated
to the teachings of the two fingers
uh send confessors out to follow the
guidance of grace the confessors are
loyal servants to the two fingers ready
to hunt down and quietly dispose of
their enemies yep that pretty much
confirms that so the confessors
were
the assassins for the two fingers okay
cool
neat
maybe try a grace mimic
maybe
it's like what is
that for a second
it's a usable tool right yep
huh
i think it always does that huh
pointing here though
nothing there
i think it always shows the way
okay
yeah
which way is this point
so it's this way
yeah it's pointing toward back here that
that makes sense okay
it's already gone too
let's try uh like a dragon thing
actually
so i think that might be let's try
plasti-du sax because you get like one
of his
things don't you
yep
class do sex ruin
i do want to try eldon stars as well
though okay
trying stuff we're trying let me do this
really quick because this kind of just
goes right in the ground
i'm just saying like how hype would it
be if we just started moving up or down
just saying that would be so sick
okay it's not gonna happen though we we
are really pushing it here
we are really pushing
what we know about this game right now
lead the way
where's it going does it just go around
randomly
i wonder does it always go
straight
what if i shot this directly into the
emblem up there
we're gonna have to try and hit it like
this
little high potentially no it's going
lower
oh
i don't know if that was just short
or not
let's go like this
because i don't know how accurate this
is
yeah it kind of does whatever it wants
huh
yeah it's not even reaching okay
let's do sex
damn it
hmm
[Music]
read three wolves spirit acid acid ashes
god i can't talk
okay
three wolves
three wolves for her right
these are called lone wolves is this
what you're talking about
spirits of bulls
well it is three
spirit of wolves chased from their pack
they later encountered a nameless
tarnished who welcomed them as hunting
companions
the wolf spirits overwhelm enemies with
their agility aiding in summer combat
should i summon them
like
do the summon
i don't know if i can summon here though
can i
oh i can't
is there like a summoning thing
i don't think there is
no it's because we already beat him
no empirians are tarnished well i didn't
think it would be
that doesn't mean that that person up
there is the three wolves that it's
talking about in the summon thing
you know what i'm saying
doesn't necessarily mean that
lonely space bean
thanks for becoming a member dude i
appreciate you man three months in a row
you're a boss thank you so much
well we're a little late on the boss
fight
ronnie gave us the wolves of torrance
former master
hughes also knew the blue-eyed spirit
caller
true are all tarnished related to
godfrey i just had this epiphany right
now like just thought of this right now
do you guys think
that
who like who were we
before all of this right
i i wonder
who
like because in the opening cut scene we
see us like rise up
in the fog or whatever
and we just
get called by grace
a tarnished of no renown but who's
saying that right like just
i don't know like how much does that
narrator know right
how much does he really know
i don't know
harness from nowhere now i guess that
means we're nobody but maybe that's not
true
you're convinced this is saint trina
okay let's keep trying things
uh
kind of tried all that let me get a bit
closer with these elven stars
like maybe we do only need to be like
right here let me try and hit it
that could not have been better
white literally could not have been
better
jon snow right exactly
looks like the hair on mikala okay let's
take a really good look at this statue
here and then we're gonna go look at
another statue okay let's try and think
of who this could be so we've got this
like
twig in her hair
with a
there's a headband in there for sure
think of this style
got a good look at the face
um is that a braid that's a pretty
shitty braid i ain't gonna cap
i ain't gonna cap but again it is a
stone statue
okay now we're going to go look
up in the halig tree
um
is it inner wall that we fight him where
do we fight uh
right here
this one
this has three
is that the same
hey my hair is in a ponytail right now
just saying
i don't know how to braid my hair is not
long enough for that but it's pretty
long
it looks kind of similar not quite
though
who knows maybe she got a new
brown you know what i'm saying
also didn't see this on her head right
here either
what about you
what do you got rocking here
crown on the head
brown on the head
um
you guys think this is america mykolo
and melania
when they were kids and she was just
younger
i'm i'm assuming that's america michela
millenia
it's younger
hey why don't we try [ __ ] right here huh
[Music]
on the statue
oh shoot
did that just light up
no
i don't think melon is a real person
guys
he's just like a fragment of america
and it goes right at it
interesting
that girl was born rotten
does one of them have one arm
we got two arms on the girl the big girl
here
we got one arm hug going on
one arm hug is it rap in here
which arm is is melanoma missing not
melano
melania which arm is melania missing
okay this one has two
it's her right arm it's the one we can't
see
from software does this [ __ ] on purpose
i swear to god
all right
also aren't they twins like why is this
one so much bigger
and they're like kind of the same size
kinda
[Music]
adhd distracted
[Music]
i just want to see what was up here okay
sorry
right nichola doesn't grow
[Music]
oh yeah hey mikala doesn't grow guys but
he's getting apparently mickel is
getting [ __ ] huge down under over
here by the way
although it could be growing because of
the cocoon that is very true i agree
hmm
that didn't work
right he stays the same age i'm trying
darkness
[Music]
hell was that
jake the one who has the crown on their
head is mykla how
scarlet flower in front of it okay let
me get to a thingy
i'm gonna use regression
and scarlet
yeah the flower
yeah they all have crowns
you forehead
okay
i think we should always have law of
aggression if we're gonna just be doing
this the entire time
i think it's a good idea to do this
stuff i really do
where is it can't see
okay
you and then scarlet aeonia
let's just try that
i think mikkel is the haleg tree
that's just me though
all right
everybody metal babe five
your moderator is mikala
everybody pog
change
do the thing
do it
[ __ ] a year all right
i'm gonna eat in here
personally i think mikkel is dead i
really do think that but i could be
wrong
that's so lit
whole lot of nothing happening here guys
a whole lot of nothing
my adhd is rocking right now
mikala is leonard
i'll get really close
[Music]
what about the other statue isn't there
another statue right here
not
there
canopy
no that's not it
michelin lard
mic lenard
this
that's definitely melania
and miklo right
because we're missing her right arm
definitely melania
is a this is the melania i would like to
meet not the one that attacks me before
i can tell her where potentially her
brother is
that's all she wants
oh yeah the roth's already over her eyes
here and everything
we're missing our arm
it's not over her eyes yet he's got him
closed up
also wasn't somebody telling us that um
mikola could be both genders isn't that
right could be a boy and a girl
[Music]
a breery
or isn't a gender is just yeah
i know i
why does melania attack us immediately
doesn't that bother you guys
why does everything in this game just
try and kill us right away
why
felenia doesn't have her crown here does
she
he does
definitely has the headband crown thing
going on
he knows no defeat i ain't trying to
kill her dog
i'm like cool with just talking i'm fine
with that
he's hard as hell i don't want to fight
her
you know how many times i died to her
a lot
a lot of times
she's the blade of mickela dude i know
where he is dude maybe
and she doesn't even try to talk she's
like bye
you ho
i'm gonna kill you
i've never known defeat i'm not trying
to fight
probably all the great runes in our
pockets why does she still want them all
right i'm doing the thing
okay sorry i thought
like maybe
we got detail on this thing nevermind
flower power
excellent
maybe on top of this thing
nobody wants to tarnish to be elden lord
that ain't up to me either
i'm just walking around honestly just
like all you
right
walking around seeing what happens when
i go into certain places right
that's all we're doing
oh my god it's jake long hair
where have you been my guy what up dude
i want to say that jake longhair in the
chat
was one of the five people in my twitch
chat
just saying
had about five people average on twitch
guys we were killing it over there
big numbers
make chaos
hey
the world
i mean should we go more in on this too
because i made this video like a month
ago
um
let's change change subjects here
because we're not getting anywhere guys
but
do you guys think
that the two fingers after we killed
radon
fell from space and went into this
crater right here
i'm like 99
sure that's what happened
her radon held her two fingers in the
sky and then when we killed her with all
the stars falling goes right into this
crater
and then she goes down there to finish
the job with the finger slayer blade
that has to be it
why else is there a crater here
with starlight shards all over the place
yes this is the ronnie crater
i can't think of another reason
also no matter what she's always down
here
but i think that's just because we're
glitching out like we have everything
before we're even there technically
um
you know what you know what i'm gonna do
i
i'm gonna do this chat i have never done
this on youtube yet
metal babe can you please ban the honey
badger
i've never done this before i've never
banned anybody on youtube
but i don't like you you are pissing me
off with you telling me what to do over
and over again i'm not a fan of it my
friend
just go geet
don't do that
thank you
that is i've i've been streaming on
youtube for like what three four months
now i don't think we've banned anybody
that might be the first person we've
ever banned besides bots no cap but when
you're in here going do this now
shut up
that's not cool
i'm not going to
okay if you ask nicely i may have
but here she is guys
and then she took the finger slayer
blade
that we gave her and ripped this thing a
new butthole
and it's a big
butthole dog
big
like she stuck it in here right here and
went
[Music]
yeah
right
her fingers are long dude
who's igp
anything back here no
nice
why she without her dress though
i think she went hard here
like she went hard in the paint
watts kill
like she had to take off the clothes for
this one type of deal you know what i'm
saying
thank you metal
okay
i believe this is her actual doll yes
can we get a close-up of the rune of
death
not anymore
no fully modeled eye
just taking a look here the detail's
insane with the
like doll stringy stuff
you know what i mean
do you think the scarlet rot may also be
messing up melania mentally like it did
with radon oh a hundred percent on your
percent and thank you for the five euro
super chat
thank you patty
that's a really good point maybe she
does attack us just because she's out of
her [ __ ] mind dude that's a great
point
very good point
thank you very
much like maybe if she wasn't bonkers
she wouldn't just attack us and be like
hey just so you know i have some
information that you might care about
she went hollow exactly
should we just do this i think i can
just i don't even i don't have the ring
i haven't done any of a quest line but
if you if you can somehow get yourself
here guys
this is always here
no matter what which you're not ever
supposed to be here i'm i'm hacking
obviously but let's just do this
everyone's insane is the answer to
everything
yeah
yeah
i mean i don't think ronnie's insane
is she
i mean okay yeah
okay everyone's a little bit nuts even
in real life
you can't deny that all of you are a
little weird don't you think
also she already has a ring
she's a murderer how how many people do
you think we've killed in the lands
between
thousands
why is her two fingers
massive
massively bigger than the other two
fingers
or is it maybe i'm off there
no
a little bit
but thank you again patty i appreciate
you man
thank you
hey okay what's she look like here
little side eye action
hmm what is this oh it's just like the
siding of her coat
what would happen if i just left
has anyone ever done that
what's she looking at
it's a pool of blood
how is this like this
why is there a pool of blood here
like she was just sitting there did she
like booty stomp it
i'm leaving you on red peace
dude she don't give a [ __ ] about that
perhaps it is precisely what i deserve
for surrendering myself to delusion
damn it chat
you don't get the sword
well
she did not like that at all i've never
heard that dialogue before that's pretty
cool
what part of the hand is ronnie's two
fingers on
damn it chat
can we still get the ending let's go
find out
that's a good question
let's go find out
regression
don't do [ __ ]
we'll try that too
we'll get if we don't see it at the
ending here we will go
to muriel do the thingy
come back
i am literally just telling him guys
should we watch this or no
actually i really like the music here
sure
worst boss in the game well one of the
worst
elden bees ratagon's awesome eldon beast
is trash in my opinion
really cool looking but a terrible fight
because dialogue at her grace irani's
rise we need to go we need to go do that
we do after i do this
we should have been able to use torrent
for this fight it seems designed for
that however it could be in the lore
why we can't use touring
like maybe torrent like cannot be
summoned in the archery
right
this music reminds me of avatar
the
you know with all the blue the blue
alien people
that one
i love it
isn't torrent what the [ __ ] isn't
torrent's former master vike
nerd
elden beast is a manifestation of the
greater will i would assume
[Music]
you don't know who vike is
this fight's really nice when it's not
constantly running away from me
[Music]
did bike have a finger maiden
yep mike's literally the guy on the
cover art
that's confirmed
same armor
it's based on attack on titan okay so no
ronnie ending guys
because we didn't talk to her but we're
gonna go
should we go to muriel first actually
let's check ronnie's rise
like maybe she'll see us and just
immediately murder us
who knows
um
or we'll need to go to muriel and do the
thingy
okay
muriel help
turtle dog pope
you're tarnished aren't you yes
your sins are absolved it's just that
easy guys
go kneel in front of uh
[Music]
a statue
all your sins
gone
okay so now what
like i atone for my sins but what does
that mean
what are the biggest changes in the
latest patch
rivers of blood is crash
bloodhound step is trash
mainly like pvp and you can use your uh
your invasion sign anywhere and it'll
take you to anywhere on the map where
there is an invasion available
which is really a fantastic idea
ronnie
are we chilling
did i mess up guys
yeah it's just dodge now
try going back to her two fingers
yes mommy
yeah is that how this works like you
just go talk to him again
and like not murder them in front of
them
i love how ronnie just like blocks any
attack that you throw at her and she's
like what the [ __ ] like doesn't even
care at all
like what are you doing bro
wrong oh god
oh god she's scary okay okay
okay
so it was
i go now to the night sky
it is there i shall find mine order
i bid thee
travel the path of the lord
and once all is done
we shall see each other
once more
muggers
the power of the turtle pope
okay now we go back
it's a very healthy relationship there's
a lot of space that we give each other
here
right now it's available again
did you guys see my video from last week
where i think the moon here is a portal
what do y'all think of that
it's like literally the same style as a
send-in gate
nice
what's the theory go watch the video
let's watch it
i'm a ronnie simp
is metal babe your girlfriend
no
but i'm about to i'm gonna go visit her
in los angeles next week if that tells
you anything
i'm gonna be gone all next week
just to visit metal bait by the way
and i've never been to la
the battle is over i see
i should have a couple videos ready for
when i'm gone
i've gone through the floor and it's an
endless pit of nothing here
i would love to see the lands between
before the shattering too oh my god
another character i think we would just
talk to instead of fight against would
be radon don't you guys think
he'd be like just a
boss just be cool i do solemnly swear
can we go irl to see metal babe
i mean if you guys are in la
uh between the 15th and the 19th let me
know
a thousand years
under the wisdom of the moon
hi fitz how are you here making it the
chill night that encompasses all that is
such ascending gate look at look at the
animation going in right there and the
fog is going in there as well
for sure
doubt
and loneliness
as the path stretches into darkness
ronnie says a lot of confusing words
doesn't she
but goes where
i have no
idea
somewhere not here
we're going to the dark moon we should
read the description of her darkmoon
spell
well then
shall we
does kind of look like a beast eye
my fair consort eternal
we're going to the moon [ __ ] it
goes to the dlc
yeah
oh wait did i miss the dialogue
[Music]
yay good job guys
claps in the chat we finished the game
great job
only took us
oh wait no
only took us like 30 minutes or whatever
okay speed run
initiated
clap clap clap clap clap
i think i missed the dialogue though
unfortunately
i live in missouri
moon is the original arc
man we have been all over the place
today we have no
like
absolutely
no
uh organization to today whatsoever
missouri sounds misery
it has its moments
of being cool
i wouldn't use the word cool actually
nerd
i'm married to ronnie the witch i'm not
maidenless you
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
absolutely annihilated
i'm the elden lord dude
actually no i'm
ronnie's simp
just [ __ ]
time to travel to the moon
are there more rays of light in the sky
now
after the ronnie ending
i don't remember these being here like
this
usually we only see those rays of light
uh
for
at the moonlight altered
how did you meet metal babe
you guys want the story of how i met
metal bid
it's actually adorable
[Music]
all the way back in 2018 i was streaming
dark souls
to two people
when i first started streaming on twitch
and she randomly came in the chat
and then
we became really good friends after that
and she has been through all the
different arcs of agt jake
he was around when i was jake from state
farm when i was adt jake all of it when
i
uh
went viral for valerian and then rocket
league and now eldon ring
it is very cool
but it all started with dark souls
my first time i ever played dark souls
dark souls 1.
[Music]
there's so many things we could talk
about holy [ __ ]
i don't even know what where to start
so adorable
i mean her favorite game ever is dark
souls 1.
i haven't really been in this area right
here in a while
i talked to a girl once
you think we'll kill another god
in dlc i don't know maybe
that is very true jake yes it is
my character's super strong
what is this statue up here
[Music]
do we know anything about this
who is this
who
[Music]
headless
i don't think so
this has like a tarp over his head
we
gold mask
i don't think so
cocoon michala
let's take a look at this big old arm
here
yeah the guy holding this person is
jacked
okay
moog and mickala huh
thank you roon i'm glad you're here
where's another one of these isn't there
one in altus plateau
uh excuse me i'm so zoey
i'm so sorry
where where is it up here
it's like near here right
wait
red hair champion
if i'm thinking of red hair champion
that would be ratagon right
muriel even refers to him as a champion
not that
[Music]
i'm lost
how'd you get 99 stops for everything
hacks
not sure mitch black knife catacombs
is that what it's called
[Music]
wait
i know it's an altus plateau
[Music]
it's south from here
is it let's go this way
yeah it's not over here is it
no
who is going after me right now
heroes grave all the statues on them i
believe
yeah it's called hero's grave that's
right
let me kill these guys real quick
like in fast travel
is there is it not an altus plateau
there it is
sainted heroes grave
so i was like it's gotta be here it's
gotta be yeah it's outside of here
though right yeah yeah yeah
wake me up
what are you trying to look for right
now we are all over the place today
which maybe i should pick a subject for
every stream and then we go on that the
entire time
maybe that would be a bit better instead
of me going like hi chat what do you
want to talk about and then everyone's
like every different thing ever and then
it's really hard
to pick anything
we're just looking around
is there a black knife assassin like
right outside this door
this is the same interest that we came
up on yeah i have to like not be in oh
no
oh
we're stuck
there it is
oh no
same statue though we learned what we
needed to learn
same exact statue
so this is just another place where the
tarnish rose and came out of
yeah we could beat the boss and leave
but that means i have to go through the
whole puzzle
what happens if i do this
let me just
do one of these
like dog i don't want to do the puzzle
i just don't
ass
all right
what's up with the mausoleums they are
basically coffins for soulless demigods
right
oh wait
why did bear command banish godfrey to
get him out of the lands between before
she shatters the elven ring
this is not one of the easier ones
at
all
this is one of the harder ones
gotta do all the shadow crap
well i guess i'm strong as hell
oh all right we have to do it because i
can't leave
actually nothing's going to attack me
nothing attacks me
yeah
nerd
wow
do i have to kill these guys to progress
the level
why are you attacking
you thought your gpu was glitching
that scared me
i'm mad about that
cool
dog
area
how big is this place
oh god
this was not the place to get stuck
all right i have an idea
we're bringing out the hacks ladies and
gentlemen we're bringing out the hacks
here we go
hold
hold
wait
uh
downloads
speed engine
excellent
heck is elden ring
he's already on whoops
yes
grips
uh
[Music]
right anywhere
you teleport me
please
player
super armor animation
gestures resistance i don't remember how
to get out of here
basic scripts
okay we're not
permanently unlock permanently unlock
maps
go all sites of grace
we're already doing that though and i
can't leave
some deep lore here
we're name
i'm missing something here
come on jake figure it out
summon anywhere permanently unlock the
maps warp
anywhere but here please
there we go
we out
we go
perfect
excellent
we're out of there
i'm messing with the elden ring
i am
i'll do whatever it takes to figure this
game out
people can contain the frenzy others
have physical changes like hyeta's eyes
melting
[Music]
and check out the frenzied village
right there
hey moog
i'll use this on you
wait can i use this shackle
whoa hey what
he did not like that uh
what the heck
you just switched spots okay
there's a shackle okay here we go
haha
idiot
yeah i almost had to actually fight
you imagine
get some beef with that pillar
three
the hardest platforming section in all
of from software
let's take a little break and listen to
some nice music
hello
goodbye
where is he
a bit lower
[Music]
there you are
[Music]
it's a sound effect
[Music]
hey
[Music]
this is gearman's theme
is it
[Music]
look at the detail on this hand right
here
like on his movements
[Music]
like when he was does the end
he'll like move his hand like exactly
how you would if you were to play this
[Music]
look at that he's shaking his hand to
make that sound that's awesome
the fingers tweaking out a bit
[Music]
this looks like legitimate hand
movements
like how you would actually play this
right
does anyone in chat like play the violin
or the guitar does this seem like pretty
close
[Music]
why put so much detail on this
[Music]
motion captured
and then it's just like bro
i'm gonna eat
you nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
this is a very tragic area
[Music]
this guy's alive right here
[Music]
looks like a girl
it's been on a loop for thousands of
years
[Music]
these are all coffins right
anything in them
he saw a face in his mouth
[Music]
nope
[Music]
wow
it's just a light source
it's still all loaded in
[Music]
i don't even want to attempt this [ __ ]
i'm not even i am not going to do the
the platforming there
nope
no
shot no thanks i'm gonna be right down
here
let's look in um
let's look in here
without actually opening it
oh
what the [ __ ]
well nothing's pre-loaded in here
except
that that's kind of weird
that like where the doors end up
kinda
there's just nothing in here
corpse wax
yeah it only exists in the cutscene
yeah turn on some other sounds
bless me
okay
[Music]
in terrasante
[Music]
let's talk to our girl
if you intend to claim the frenzied
flame
i ask that you cease
it is not to be meddled with
it is chaos
devouring life and thought unending
however ruined this world has become
however mired in torment and despair go
check out the merchant by the gold mass
teleporter okay
there is beauty in that
is there not
if you would become lord
do not deny this notion
please
leave the frenzied flame alone
yes mommy
okay
frenzy uh
gold mass teleporter it's like on the
other side
oh
the bridge right here
can't let my lady die
i mean
that's that's
[Music]
[Music]
wait i have it hold on i don't have to
look it up
[Music]
look at my character
okay
old
old
[Music]
[Music]
where'd it go
[Music]
oh screw it
you said it's the gearman opening or
like is the ost
[Music]
you guys hear it
[Music]
yeah right here it does
[Music]
this is my favorite ost of any souls
game
this has got to be as good as it gets
[Music]
it really if this match is
right on for sure
it's creating a very good melody
especially when it goes quiet in the
gear main theme
the merchants are messengers
you mean the little dudes from
bloodborne
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah right here
right here you can hear it
with what the merchant's playing
[Music]
a hundred percent yeah
yep
100
god that song is so [ __ ] good dude
it's so incredibly good
it has 11 million views on youtube by
the way that's insane
but that i think that's the best song
i've ever heard in a video game for sure
[Music]
it's called gear main the first hunter
gearman
you guys want to scare him
[Music]
second face
what do you have
i already have these things
nothing to choose
then
when are the cha what are the chances
bloodborne getting a pc port
i have said this if re if bloodborne 2
or
bloodborne remastered what the hell was
that
or blood bloodborne remastered
comes out on pc or whatever i think it
would sell
just as good if not better than eldon
ring
how many people here in chat have played
bloodborne before
item but
i'll do whatever you guys say
i said
[Music]
don't have i ever done
what was that
why didn't this go
i i've never heard that before what the
heck was that
i had no idea it made that sound
what the heck was that
dude
i know it was mean but now we know that
he has a funny laugh
it seems like a lot of people have
played a bloodborne
is um
is elden ring your favorite from
software game
yay or nay
yeah i always feel bad for killing them
too
well now i know that's what that what
happens there
rip this guy
ney yay nay
yeah from what i played nay
it's that hero
i don't know
sekiro
i i thought elden ring was my favorite
and the more i've played it the more i
appreciate
it for what it is
but
i think i like dark souls 3 more
for what it is
because those games aren't open world
games so i have to kind of think of them
in a different
light right
so
like eldon rings my favorite open world
game
but i don't think it's my favorite from
software game
i i think that goes to dark souls 3 just
because
i that was my first
and obviously i'm gonna like my first
from software game more than
you know like even maybe if i played
dark souls 2 first that would have been
my favorite i don't know
but i i love that game dark souls 3 is
so good
yeah dark souls 2 is very ugly i'm not a
fan of the art design in it
not a fan of i'm really not a fan of the
game at all but
elden rings your first
have you
if elden ring was your first did you go
and play the other ones as well
like afterward
i can't imagine how much the player
count of all the previous games
increased after elden ring
because eldon ring like blew
their previous player base out of the
water
like it wasn't even close
who knows
i think my i think my favorite is a tie
between um
i think it's a tie between
bloodborne and dark souls 3 for me
for my favorite from software game
but i think eldon ring is the best open
world game ever made
why is this apostle chilling in the
village my theory like my guess on that
is that all of those ladies down there
just skinned
new clothes for him and he just like put
it on
i i love sakiro's
sakiro has the best combat of any from
software game
uh well eldon rings pretty far up there
when it comes to eldon ring era
combat i really like the combat in this
game i think it's fun like the ashes of
war and the incan like spells and
incantations are really freaking good
um
but sekiro's combat is just
so fluent and perfect it's like playing
uh a rhythm game
you know
skyrim was the foundation
yeah i mean skyrim is fantastic
like at the time but i think elden ring
like skyrim's the foundation of how open
world games should be elden ring hits
all of those marks that that skyrim did
and then just expanded on it and it
perfected every other bit of it does
that make sense
so like
skyrim in 2011 was like the pinnacle of
gaming and i think eldon ring in 2022 is
the pinnacle of gaming right now so
maybe in
2033 we'll have a new pinnacle of gaming
somewhere along the line you know i mean
i think if you've only played elden ring
going to dark souls 3 will be the the
the easiest
most fluent
uh going from one game to the next the
elden ring is a very much like dark
souls 3
very much
spekiro did win game of the year
what was sakiro competing against though
that's the other part of it
yeah it good transition thank you ash
that's that's what i meant
nicholas an avatar
the last airbender
he was competing at death against death
stranding yeah no one's gonna pick death
stranding man
god of war came out in 2018 so it wasn't
competing against that
that kiro was 2019.
favorite boss theme from from software
what we just listened to
uh
gearman from bloodborne that's the best
uh
musical theme i've ever heard in a game
before i think
i hope eldon ring wins game of the year
but i
i think god of war will compete against
it
for sure
it's like god of war 2018 was so good
it's such a good game
oh maybe i'm misunderstanding what you
mean by boss theme
i mean it's gonna compete against uh god
of war so
i think god of war's got the
has a great chance of winning game of
the year too
the lord of cinder is very cool
it's a nice nod to dark souls 1.
irani
majula's hub music is
very good it's a different type of
you know i mean
different vibe
definitely a different vibe
it was competing at that yeah death
stranding
ragnarok will win because lots of game
journalists really hate from software
games
here's the thing
i
i don't think
that god of war ragnarok is going to
make enough changes from the god of war
in 2018
to truly
warrant
a game of the year
it's gonna be a sequel
to a game that came out four years ago
like eldon ring expanded
so hard
they really didn't have to go this hard
with this game they really didn't
like in almost every aspect elden ring
is just like a better
open world game
you know
but like is god of war ragnarok gonna
make all of those changes
where i can say the same
you know
because i'm not gonna like
press one in chat if you agree with me
on this i don't give a [ __ ] about
graphics
i don't care how good a cinematic looks
in a game i don't care
if the gameplay sucks i don't want to
play your game
that's the most important thing about a
game is the gameplay being fun i don't
care at all about graphics like maybe
maybe a tad like if the game looked like
trash
then you know we'd have a different
discussion but there are tons of games
out there
that look
bad in comparison to like whatever like
a game that focuses on graphics and the
gameplay is just better
you know
like uh great example
horizon forbidden west
that game is beautiful it looks amazing
i got bored two hours in and stopped
playing it
an hour in it's boring it's a boring
game
i didn't want to play it
but it looked amazing
didn't like it
that's that's my comparison
but some people are super hung up on
graphics
yeah i mean i just didn't i didn't like
it
i i would go if i wanted to play horizon
forbidden west and have the same
experience i would go watch a movie
because i'm basically just sitting there
watching it
a lot of the time
and then the story is just like being
spoon fed to me right like just
explaining everything and talking
through everything with every character
that we come across
maybe that's just because i'm used to
like elden ring telling me absolutely
[ __ ] nothing
but
man
the story in eldering is
insane like the level of detail this
goes into is absurd level of
environmental storytelling whereas like
i'm just sitting there listening to
characters in a video game tell me
everything
i'm like okay
can i play can i figure this out on my
own or am i too stupid for that you know
felt the same but the last was too
i mean this might be a hot take but i
think last was two is
awesome
i love it
it's one of my favorite games ever
and i think the story is much better
than people are letting on
i think people were mad when it came out
for the wrong reasons
not for wrong reasons
i could see why people are upset with
the story
of last of us too
but i've it made sense to me
maybe it was just me though you know
what i mean
i i think it just depends on the type of
person you are hold on
eat
you know
no i've never played eternal
they're just bots it's fine
yeah a lot of a lot of people thought
last was two was very like
it was bad or the storyline the plot
made no sense
which i disagreed with people who said
that um
giga
i loved it
like a lot of people got to the end of
the game and they did they thought it
didn't make sense whereas i was
i was the exact opposite
so
yeah
nope never played mortal shell i have
heard of it though
yeah thundercock
we were kind of all over the place today
weren't we
i'll try and be more organized next time
i do this because we just kind of talked
about anything and everything today
but it was fun actually had fun
yeah it's all preference jm it is
like if if some people just don't like
here's here's what i don't agree with it
i i had people in my chat on twitch when
when elden ring first came out
that had never played elden ring and
they said
no i think elden rings bad
and they've never played it
they never touched it
and they were saying that the game was
bad and i'm like you can't say a game's
bad when you've never played the game
you can have an opinion when you've
played it
but if you haven't played it
i don't care about what you're talking
about
but some people
they
they think they can
i'm like
okay
i disagree
but if you've played the game and you
don't like it totally fair
totally
favorite indie game
let me think about that
little nightmares
you guys play little nightmares is that
an indie game maybe not
little nightmares one and two are two of
my favorite games ever those games are
sick
like little horror
love it
i think it's an indie game
yeah it's bandai though
can we look at the rune on the corpse
yep
it's not a rune though right
i always look at this when i um like
investigate this body
the scar on her back
i know it's the curse mark
yeah journey's fantastic as well
yeah hades is really good
ronnie's body here is so different
compared to
her doll form
i really would want to know what ronnie
looks like before
she is the doll because i mean we can
see her here but we obviously can't
really tell
you know
hollow knight is really good
i haven't played terraria before
it's just ronaldo with ryegon's hair
have you guys seen this anywhere else
this bracelet as well
definitely had red hair
for sure
but the body's so charred
is goron thing in here is is goron a
thing
it's either purple or like red it's like
a ruby color
oh we get a close-up on the
the dog i just thought of that
i don't know if anyone's ever done this
i know he can do it though
debate parlor yeah
if i go in here with this hack it won't
attack me it'll just sit there
[Music]
it has some pretty interesting features
it's got ear piercings
it's pretty cool
you go boy yes you are you got a big
snoot
look at your big snoot
big snoot
can you tell i have a dog of my own
got some
bracelets in here
hold on
kurima
one of the only animes i've watched is
naruto
i'm looking at this because it looks
like
the bracelet godwin wears
i'm gonna cap
look at those big mittens
you got big paws
don't call me a weeb
big old what is it staring at
this here
broken window you can jump through here
can't you
or something like that
oh god it's not even loaded
yeah and then there's items up here
yep
he's still a puppy
check behind the banner
i think it's just a
bookshelf
yep
this could be another uh potential like
entering of a dlc type of thing
is this room
like something to do with this
and then
nicholas hand is another one or
whoever's in the cocoon i'm not even
calling that person mikala anymore
i am so like determined to prove that
that's not mikala
but it it could be it probably is
i miss sif well you killed him didn't
you
what do you hope for for dlc literally
anything that would be great
that would be great literally anything
would be great
right guys
literally anything would be cool with me
what hair color does mikola have we
think blonde
the three wolves in malaccaps arena
wait are there three i only thought they
were two red no there are three
there's one in a dungeon right
hold on
good point
let me look at that uh
statue again
red wolf is ratagon blide and malacath
[Music]
no these three wolves
i just noticed the snoot when i was
going oh big snoot
it had like a curve right here
but
these are much smaller
and maybe that's just how they design
them
ratagon is america
this is true
they're very small though
but maybe they were puppies here
you know
nah from software won't do you dirty
stranger they'll be like it'll dlc for
this game will be 15 or 20 bucks
and then it'll give you like hours of
new content
this could be baby ratagon with three
pups
okay
is there
is there something in ratagan's hair
when we fight him
it doesn't look like that does it i
don't think there's anything in his hair
no he doesn't
i didn't think so
we
whoa
oh okay it's just from the tree
oh god
i'm upside down somehow
oh okay
where's the tree let's go up here
look
when did america and radagon become
one we don't know my guy
i want to meet ranala pre-insanity as
well
there's so many things i want
but are we gonna get it
probably not
karina's lily in the hair
i'm staring at it to get a
picture on it
a symbol of faith in saint trina
okay we're looking
um
not enough for me to say like yeah
you know
yeah
not quite
nicholas lilly
hold
i have to do it like this sorry
um
no
don't think so
might be stretching there
that's what we're here for to [ __ ]
stretch baby
we find a lot of this and they make it
seem so important
ghostworth
goes right
go sport
ah it doesn't look like that to me
looks like selling's some someone said
that earlier
do we know
what selling looks like outside of her
her helmet her weird-ass helmet
here
yeah they look too different for me to
be like one way or the other
have you read every single item probably
[Music]
[Music]
lily unmasked some pcs i mean we can
kind of see it like right here right the
flower pattern on the helmet
well actually she's
where we just were hold on
there's like a literal picture of her
here
yeah those noises are creepy
um right here
that's selling right
i can't really tell there
is a different picture of her over here
oh she's always looking down
zolian master
zul he's awesome
he doesn't look objectively evil to me
feels like a little smile
these people look evil to me
yeah that's definitely her
look at ronaldo she's like
ready to bust a cap in that ass
your actual character face looks amazing
should i look it up i haven't seen that
yet
what uh what video is that from from
zolly
sully the witch
and there's 200 people here
by the way i subscribe to zero people
on my channel i have my own channel that
i subscribe to people on just so you
know
i support her on on uh my own
not agt channel
just unmasking let me look that up
unmasking
npcs have unique faces again
hidden faces of enemies or this one
varys
oh okay
oh god
he looks like a boot
irena edgar jarren riot
de los lana
oh it's this one
there she be
someone has a second face set after you
put her into a new body her hair changes
a little
it's smack's forehead
hot spot spots
okay
howdy why do you spam bro stop
talking about some other stuff
howdy i'm sorry to do this to you man
but i just think you're way too young to
be here i really do i'm sorry dude
you're i'm constantly having to tell you
to stop doing things
he's even told me that he's super young
as well
so i feel bad but there it is
bye
sorry
you like the straight up told me that
he's super young
ellen's pretty hot is that what
everyone's saying
not you know
yeah
she's pretty good looking
well it's cooking good looking
all right
hold on
perfect
life lesson for the little bloke yeah i
mean he just he comes in chat he spams
his own thing all the time he says like
words that you shouldn't say in a chat
room like kind of like a young kid who
just like randomly saying some things
that you shouldn't say
uh
don't like it
so sorry dude and he's literally told me
like on twitter before that he's like
under the age of 12. like it's quite
young
so sorry man nothing crazy like
you know
he'll grow up and he'll be fine
you guys think melania drives a honda
accord
what a dumb question of course she does
you guys know you could go this way
hello
and go on like the rooftops
got a honda fit
yeah we kind of stopped lower hunting a
little bit it's hard to lure hunt when
there's so many things to talk about
that we just talk about
everything
yep this is where you learn platforming
for sure
oh yeah we already know that cage
definitely
favorite weapon river the blood until
they they nerfed my rivers of blood
um my rivers of blood bleed build and
now i can't use it in pvp anymore so
instead i rated this game three months
ago a 10 out of 10 but i think now that
it's a 0 out of 10 because they nerfed
my rivers of blood
so it's just a bad game now
i've seen a lot of people saying that
[ __ ] on twitter and i'm like oh my god
it's a little hilarious
i i also used bloodhound step on my
dagger with it as well
and they nerfed that too so actually
this game now is a negative 10 out of
10.
just maulding children
all great points thank you
that's my 12 year old persona voice
how do i ban the streamer
okay i'm trolling clearly
i use bloodhound step because honestly
in my opinion i don't think there's
enough iframes for the normal dodge
button
that's where you get the second key
yeah why is the key right here like what
was this guy doing
how do i band the streamer
fit up
this is a champion's armor set
altered
the bloodhound step does kind of look
like blood-borne
dodging you're kind of right
there it is
you're trying to fight right now you're
five foot one i would demolish you
it wouldn't even be close
how tall do you think i am chad if you
had to guess
four foot nine
no
yeah i'm not eight feet tall i'm not a
freak
oh if you're that tall you're not free
you're just tall
that's right i'm five foot ten
how much do you think i weigh
because it's changed drastically
over the last few years
actually you can't see me i don't even
know how you'd be able to guess
yeah i'm only 5 foot 10.
i was 220 three years ago
but now i'm not
i could be fatter or i could be i could
have lost weight
you never know
i'm 510 and i weigh 45 pounds
i'm basically a hollowed a hollow
i'm not bald i have a ton of hair fitsy
shut up
i'm wondering why there's an inverted
statue here as well
well actually it's not inverted
see this would be another location for
potential dlc as well because we would
just put something there
where's your dog she is upstairs
she doesn't like coming down here
uh but i weigh 185 pounds now and i'm
very proud of that
but i was 220 in 2019
a lot of bad food but then i lost all
the weight so now i'm very comfortable
dog stream win
100 000 subs
we're getting there
we're actually getting close
congrats thank you
[Music]
i well i actually did it on purpose so
like i got big on purpose
uh
because i always felt felt very small
in my life like
all my friends were really tall i don't
know why
and i'm like five
i would say five nine five ten like i'm
really not that tall and i was like
probably throughout my entire life like
a buck fifty bucks sixty
one fifty one sixty and just didn't feel
very good so i'm like you know what i'm
gonna do i'm just gonna like
get big i'm gonna work out all the time
i'm gonna gain as like i bulked
basically so like when i say i was 220 i
was
i was 220 with a lot of muscle as well
like i worked out all the time but i was
probably eating between like six to
eight thousand calories a day in lifting
once or maybe even twice a day like i
got really big and what i found out is
that i don't like feeling big i don't
like it when you don't have height
to go with your weight it doesn't really
match and you just feel heavy
which sucks
so then i was like okay i don't like
that feeling i'm gonna lose
i'm gonna go back down and
we're doing that feels good
i'm not bald my hair is actually going
to my shoulders now
y'all just think i'm bald i have my
ponytail in my hat right now
i just pull my hair through the back of
my hat
a little ponytail
i don't have my camera man
until i see it it's not real you'll
literally see me in less than a week
i'm literally coming to see you
is how you lost all your hair all right
fine
oh it's way past mullet bro it's way
past mullet
we are beyond the mullet
my hair is long dude
with bald extensions
i love this area
it's so pretty out here
look at that
that is gorgeous
get some cinematic shots for the youtube
video
that probably won't make from the stream
honestly
it does have a ring city feel to it
oh god
oh not where i wanted to go what
what
much lore
look at that
look how these are loaded in the heck
take a dip let's go
i'm still holding it down
oh god
why is there an ionian bloom there
probably from one of her sisters
a new competitor for asmin bald
yeah dude the the day that i have 60 000
viewers in my chat
i'll say i can compete with asm and gold
guy's a legend it's freaking awesome i
watch him all the time
whoa
this is kind of cool shot
gaslighting chat how am i gaslighting
you guys i'm not gaslighting anybody
you goober
my gas lighting
okay
whoa everything's gotta load oh i'm i'm
stuck
god damn it
that's not gaslighting
how is that gaslighting
hey guys i'm not bald
no you're just gaslighting us into
thinking you're not bald
[Music]
no i don't want to get stuck again i'm
not going to hero's grave
you guys want to see a simp
boom
big boy simp here
no hair haven't had ass
i would say you guys are gaslighting me
potentially
are you guys gaslighting me
three
he doesn't have a face
there's nothing in there
just a full-on simply boy
just staring at his favorite picture
left some bread out here left some some
apples some more bread
probably some wine in here
this looks like a nice party
i booted imagine being bald
your hair was really short last time i
saw you and
i would rip my hair out too if i was an
rl tournament host
i don't think i have a sink like okay i
definitely do i would say like less than
one percent
of
my community from rocket league stuck
with me
into elden ring
i would say my community's completely
different except for like the five to
ten outliers maybe
i definitely like my alden ring
community a lot more
do we know who made these
like all of these statues that are just
here
used to do rocket league
yeah very much so
i used to do rocket league coaching
because i have like 7 500 hours in
rocket league
so i did coaching and i
i met i got about at least over 200 000
followers on tick tock from like one
minute tips
and then at certain points i averaged a
lot of viewers on rocket league on
twitch
medusa made them
okie dokie
we see the giant over here
no
[Music]
you rocket league
hey listen rocket league is
it's rocket league
it is what it is
america's tits
where you fight malaya mirai is a bunch
of statues too
do you believe all the from software
games are connected in one world
personally i do not
jake lured me in with dark souls and
then one stream one day he was driving a
car and hitting a ball
[Music]
heard rocket league has a high skill
ceiling
uh
very much so
very much so
i need to research more about these
i believe ratagon is basically a puppet
and america was a puppet of the greater
will as well until she broke out of it
by shattering the elden ring
in my opinion
all right i got to get out of here
i have an early time tomorrow people
we're gonna be playing some galt
tomorrow morning with my dad it's gonna
be fun
i gotta talk to him before he goes to
bed
but i'll probably be streaming again
tomorrow afternoon um if if not i'm i
have to actually work on a couple of
videos before i leave for la
um
we actually got a couple of new sponsors
for two more future videos which is
awesome
so that'll be great
um so look out for those between the
15th and
the 19th
um
yeah
thank you all for being here i don't
know how many people were here the whole
time but chat was moving the whole time
and i appreciate it thank you all very
much for being here
um
yeah i i
might stream again tomorrow depending on
how much work i get done
um not a golf stream not yet i do want
to figure out how to do that someday
on a second channel potentially but
we'll see
disc golf swears out golf is boring all
right all right i like it golf is hard
which is why i like it
i just like
things that are difficult for me i guess
i don't know but
i've played golf for like 20 years
since i was like a kid
um
but yeah everyone have a great night
thank you all for being here again
potentially back tomorrow
um i am leaving for los angeles next
this coming monday
to go see metal babe who's in the chat
right now um so that'll be fun so i
won't be able to stream between the 15th
and the 19th but i should have videos
ready
while i'm gone
and then probably one or two videos um
at least one more video before i leave
as well so
that'll be fun
either way
thank you all for being here really
appreciate you again and have a great
night we didn't really get anything done
today we didn't talk about anything
specifically so i'll try and work on
that for future
future stuff but
today was fun i'm glad we just can talk
about random stuff for three hours
that's cool so
thank you all have a great night and
i'll see you soon peace out dudes